One of the best books you could ever
read, Scientific Advertising written by
the Godfather himself, Claude Hopkins.
In fact, one of my favorite lines from
Scientific Advertising is this, "The
product itself should be its own best
salesman." I don't know what it is, but
in 2026, people keep shipping crap
products and they wonder why they don't
sell. They're writing great copy and
they're doing this and adding deadlines
and urgency and all this stuff. Ship a
better product. Copy is dead unless it
is propelling a great product. The great
Gary Bencivenga says, "A mighty product
is better than a mighty pen." Meaning,
you can't out copy a bad product. So,
stop writing copy for a crappy product.
Write a great product and the copy will
write itself. That is a hack.